so I wrote about something called
which is a wonderful thing to write
about because no
to check yes but I try to base my
futures on realities that are with us
today
so I'm not writing about Planet X I'm
not writing about a galaxy far far away
I'm writing about this earth in the near
future and everything that I put in has
a basis in reality something we're doing
now something we've already done
something we're thinking of doing
personal futures I write about probable
futures possible and probable how do you
think the world we have already changed
the world a lot not always for the
better
some of it's for the better as far as we
human beings are concerned but every
time we invent a new technology we like
to play with that technology and we
don't always foresee the consequences
and every time we change the source of
our of our energy we change our whole
society and our whole set of values by
which I mean that amongst
hunter-gatherers there was one set of
values amongst agriculturalists there
was another set of values amongst
carbon-based fuel people which we are at
the moment cheap energy there's another
set of values and we will now have to
develop a fourth because we could not
continue burning carbon fuels at the
rate we have been burning them without
killing ourselves
it's always a double-edged sword cuts
both ways you can't say it's a curse or
a blessing you have to look at each
piece of technology see what it
accomplishes on the positive side and
then what the side effects are on the
negative side for instance our our
ability to discover an invent has
allowed us to open the biggest Pandora's
box in the world which is the ability to
create new biological species that can
be a good thing better potatoes it can
be a bad thing more destructive microbes
so you can't say good or bad without
saying specifically what isn't the most
important thing for the world as a whole
is to maintain the oxygen level that
allows us to live on land and how are
you going to do that well first of all
you'll have to avoid killing off the
ocean because the blue-green algae in
the ocean produces sixty to eighty
percent of the oxygen that we breathe
and the oxygen that we breathe breathe
was created by the blue-green algae 1.9
billion years ago before that we didn't
have oxygen in the air so I'd say for
the world as a whole that would be
number one priority and then we can talk
about the rest as long as we know that
we're still going to be alive and that
other life-forms on the planet will be
alive too thank you